use elimination to solve for x and y and
they give us two equations here X plus
2y is equal to 6 and 4x minus 2y is
equal to 14 so the salt to solve by
elimination what we do is we're going to
add these two equations together so that
one of the two variables essentially
gets eliminated gets canceled out and
what we could do right here we see we
have a plus 2y here we see we have a
negative 2y
right over here so clearly if we added
these two together the Y's would cancel
out and so that's what exactly what
we're going to do we're going to add the
left side of this equation to the left
side of this equation and the right-hand
side of that equation to the right-hand
side of the bottom equation and just to
make it clear that this should make
sense is we're just using both of these
constraints whenever you learn about any
type of equation so when if I have X
plus 2y is equal to 6 you learned early
on in algebra that it's you can
manipulate this equation in any way as
long as whatever you do to the left-hand
side of the equation you do to the
right-hand side if this is equal to that
the only way that the Equality will
still hold is whatever you do to this
whatever you add to this or so multiply
it by you also do to the right-hand side
so when we're adding these two equations
that's exactly what we're doing we could
say hey let's add 14 to both sides of
this equation so you could add 14 on
this side you could add 14 on that side
that wouldn't be anything new but the
second equation right here tells us that
4x minus 2y is the same thing as 14 so
instead of adding 14 on the left-hand
side I could add 4x 4x minus 2y when
we're adding these two equations we're
really just adding the same thing you
could view it as we're starting with
this equation and then we're adding the
same thing to both sides on the right
hand side it looks like we're adding 14
to the 6 on the left hand side it looks
like we're adding 4x minus 2y to
whatever's on the left hand side but the
second constraint tells us that 14 and
4x minus 2i are the same thing so we're
adding the same thing to both sides so
with that said let's just do it so the
left hand side if we add it up we have X
plus 4 X is 5x and then the 2y cancels
out with the negative 2i and then on the
right hand side we have 6 plus 14 6 plus
14 is 20 so we're left with one equation
with one unknown 5x is equal to 20
we can divide both sides by five and we
are left with X is equal to four now we
can go back and substitute in x equals
four into either of these equations to
solve for y so let's use this top one so
we have 4 plus 2y is equal to 6 we can
subtract 4 from both sides so then we
get 2y is equal to 2 divide both sides
by 2 we get Y is equal to 1 so the
solution the X's and Y's that satisfy
both of these equations are X is equal
to 4 and Y is equal to 1 so this is the
solution for this system or this
coordinate would be the point of
intersection of these two lines and we
can verify it lets verify that when we
put X is equal to 1 sorry X is equal to
4 and Y is equal to 1 of this first
equation it satisfies it so we have 4
plus 2 times 1 that's 4 plus 2 that does
indeed equal 6 and then in the second
equation right over here you have 4
times 4 minus 2 times 1 minus 2 times 1
this is equal to 16 minus 2 which does
indeed equal 14 so it definitely does
satisfy both of these equations so we're
done X is equal to 4 and y is equal to 1